u.s president donald trump wrapped up
his re-election campaign
still behind in the national polls but
convinced
he'll pull off a victory and i think
we're going to have a tremendous victory
trump rallied in four different
battleground states
but made his last rally in michigan as
he did in 2016
with an 11th hour pitch to voters but if
biden and harris and the radical left
gain power they will collapse our
economy
and send our nation into a very steep
depression trump's rival former vice
president joe biden
focused on the northeastern state of
pennsylvania
calling in celebrity artists like lady
gaga to wrap up the final night
pennsylvania is the same state where
biden's campaign started
and also where he was born it's time to
stand up and take back our democracy
we can do this we can be better than
what we've been
we can be who we are at our best the
united
states of america as the candidates
presented their closing arguments
the number of americans who have voted
prior to election day
has set new records nearly 100 million
people have cast their ballots
in early voting most polls show
early mail in voting favors biden but
trump believes
his supporters are waiting until tuesday
to cast
in-person votes but in the final hours
of the campaign
both candidates signaled they may not
accept the results on election day
cheating can happen like you've never
seen this is their dream
and they are they are known for it trump
even called a recent supreme court
decision
allowing an extension to count votes in
pennsylvania
as dangerous twitter flagged the tweet
as potentially misleading with an
immediate result on election day in
doubt
both candidates are preparing potential
legal challenges to the results
under no scenario will donald trump be
declared a victory a victor on election
night casting widespread uncertainty
over poll results
now appears to be a tactic employed by
both campaigns
you know we've already seen challenges
to extended deadlines for
um allowing say mail-in ballots
that have been postmarked by election
day but that arrive a few days later
there have been challenges to
adjustments in these laws american
voters
are anxious hoarding food
and boarding up businesses from new york
to los angeles
joe biden will be in pennsylvania on
election day
donald trump will be watching the
returns come in from the white house
where two additional fences have been
erected
around the perimeter in anticipation of
civil unrest kimberly helkin al jazeera
the white house